pear things YouTube channel and welcome
to another episode of pearl daily where
I cover this week's treachery debauchery
and craziness today I have a special
guest on the channel welcome back
Christine hello thanks for having me
back so today we have a full schedule of
debauchery and craziness but guys before
we start make sure you go subscribe to
Christine's Channel we're trying to get
her to 50K it's over at Christine Grace
Smith 50k would be a great Christmas
present sir also guys also we have new
merch coming out um we have whale merch
we have women shouldn't vote sweatshirts
we have all the new merch so make sure
you go check that out the link to that
is in the description you know they they
call me a pck me constantly yeah I've
heard they say pick me Pearl pick me
Pearl's just saying this cuz she's a
pick me today I found a real life
example of a pick me wow okay I I found
one so let's pull it up seen a bunch of
stitches to her videos a lot trou
finding her Tik Tok because apparently
they keep deleting it they banned
account number three but you can't get
rid of me baby you can't get rid of me
baby account number four account number
four but her YouTube is still up and she
goes not her not her what the no that's
me guys not that one stop it but now I'm
seeing this new trend on social media
girls are fed up with the fact that they
have to work they don't want to be why
are you putting why are you bringing her
into this what guys you're you're
putting Brett into this no that's
America sweet not only that then inre
telling women to be the opposite of what
I think men want no with the actual
video of the pikme I I I give these
people's lives I make their lives too
good they don't appreciate what they
have they just are giving me all the
Sass the Sass all right play the actual
video
[Laughter]
blessing single and
available single and available yes
single and
available
have single and available that's me
that's me I'm single and
available I'm single and available if
anybody wants to
know you can stop me if you
want oh thank you I was I was trying to
okay I'm going to I'm going to go now
okay I will thank you what did he say I
will okay I'm single and available
though all right okay okay no I think
we're going to keep seeing this I think
we're going to keep seeing women
approaching men yeah I mean because men
are approach we have to right yeah cuz
men men can't approach a woman nowadays
without having to worry about getting me
toed without having to worry about
ending up on Tik Tok or being called a
creep so yeah this this was it's like I
felt the cringe in the room could you
understand what the grandpa was saying
no I couldn't understand what he was
saying it sounded like he said something
along the lines of you're fine the way
you are that's what I heard that's what
I heard too but you know it's like we
get called a pck me left and right oh
she's just a pck me I found you guys an
actual pick me I mean I don't know what
more she wants to be picked someone pick
her and I'm like cuz this is I I think
we're going to keep seeing this kind of
stuff I think it's going to be it
wouldn't surprise me Pedro Penna weighs
in he says yeah no one is biting except
Grandpa yeah typical woman she wants to
get picked but it's not the one she
wants picking her I look at Grandpa's
he's interested she's saying single and
available but all they're hearing is
single and desperate yeah it's cringe is
cringe Tony tones if pick me energy was
a video often times my critics and
detractors will will constantly say you
are a Pik me Pearl's a Pik me but I
thought to myself I'm like I get equal
amount of criticism from men I was like
I think some of my meanest detractors
have actually been do I'm like I don't
you guys I go just as hard well I go
pretty hard on the simps too I really
don't like simps she really doesn't like
simps
I don't like the simpy now one example
of a s that I see in the media
constantly and the reason I would call
him a s what is simpy let's talk about
simpery guys you know we we throw this
term around and they think what does
that even mean simpy is in its Essence
putting a woman on a pedestal right so
an example of sing is these guys that
just say my wife is the most amazing
special awesome person I know yeah I
would say you're actually quite quite
harsh on the the simpy thing you you're
off for like someone being a simp is is
pretty yeah yeah well and there's
nothing wrong with saying those things
in itself about your wife I'd like to
clarify the problem is when they almost
refer to their wife like she is a
goddess yeah yeah and and it's like the
language they they speak of her like she
is this goddess woman that is so amazing
and special and awesome and really she's
just a normal chick yeah one example of
a guy that I think is a bit simpy as
John Legend he is a completely out of
order wife that he barely he barely
checks and kind of just lets her do
whatever she wants okay I think that's
simping you can't just let your chick do
whatever whatever she wants and this is
one thing I I've been studying wives
that I think are better representatives
of wives so like I look at um not Megan
Markle the other one Kate Middleton Kate
Middleton I think she's an example of a
wife we can look up to another example
of a wife we can look up to is Melania
Trump and when I think of examples of
bad wi one of the first ones that come
to my head is Chrissy Teegan I mean
there's so many we can think be real yes
but Christy Tegan especially and one
thing is because this woman is just
always saying too much on the internet
right okay so there's a clip going viral
of her asking her where is the strangest
place her and John has gotten sex that
is not for the internet yeah and well
you know I could imagine if some of the
wives I said previously were asked this
they would just say that's private it's
between husband and wife but Christy
just goes on to just tell everybody is
this the best or the worst what he do
the best okay the best um probably the
Obama thing
what John what's oh God oh God John John
what what what is what is your wife
talking about I don't know we heard in
there get back in what happened we're
not going to discuss that we're not
going to discuss it we're not we're not
oh my God Secret Service come here jump
back in hi look at joh look at I don't
we're not talking about it that's the
true that is an awesome answer not the
White House not it it was not at the W
house 100% not the I promise he was not
elected yet yeah okay anyway we're
moving on I'm
sorry I'm in trouble now okay so this
went viral for two reasons and I wanted
to ask you about this because this is
more up your lane so something triggered
me in that there CU I'm that I know that
we're talking about Chris Teegan and I
do have a fair bit say about her but the
email they mentioned Pizza in a
president's email so I'm I'm hearing all
of the conspiracies yeah yeah so so on
February 8th 2015 Christy Teegan was
asked at the Grammys about the strangest
place her and John Legend have gone
intimate she said they had sex at the
Obama thing they also reference one I
don't know what they were up to at the
Obama thing but people are speculating
that it it was some sort of weird sex
there's there's there's speculation
right and I thought to myself I'm like
he said he said in the email something
about the channels being watched or
monitored or something didn't he yeah
yeah I mean you don't know what goes on
in high places you
know I was thinking I'm like dang like
wives always snitch on their husbands
it's like I was like so many times we
just run our mouths and just snitch on
it yeah I do I don't think she should
have really answered that and even the
way she answered it she wasn't looking
to him to gauge whether she should say
something or not she was looking to the
camera and to the people interviewing
her that's one of the things I say to
look for she's learning It's like
because the women that respect their
husbands look to them first like the
same way like if they ask if someone
asks your boss something you kind of
look to them for the answer yeah yeah
it's all micro Expressions you can tell
where the sort of dominance in the
relationship is by the micro expressions
of the wife and typically wives who
don't have as much respect for their
husbands look outside of the
relationship first before they look to
the relationship CU it's only afterwards
I didn't even think about how what that
symbolizes too in a relationship because
they're looking to the world for advice
before oh because it probably reflects
in there like I don't know it's it's
weird cuz when you said that I'm like
cuz that's how they behave in their
relationship exactly because they look
to the world for validation they look to
how they're perceived by the world
rather than their husband for the
validation and how their husband
perceives them so first she looks to the
interviewer and the camera and then you
can see it in his face you can see his
face is kind of like oh why did you say
that and then it's instantly again oh
I'm in trouble but when she says I'm in
trouble she doesn't look to him she
looks to the guy who's interviewing her
when she says I'm in trouble because she
wants that validation from the outside
to be like no you're fine you're fine
she doesn't want the validation from him
right that's at least just what I picked
up right so I was recently recommended
to watch a woman named Dr Laura
Schlesinger
because I was told that I remind the
audience of her okay because of
something I said okay so I've recently
been arguing having the conversation
about cheating now I'd like to make it
clear to the audience cheating is wrong
I am not for cheating it is wrong you
should not cheat men shouldn't cheat
women shouldn't cheat but cheating for
men and women is different it's
different absolutely men can have casual
sex and it just mean nothing women even
in order to have casual sex generally
the men unless she's a complete
have to be of a certain caliber they
have to make money they have to be
attractive enough a lot of times for men
she's just there so I argue that
cheating should be worked through and it
doesn't have to be the end of the world
especially if he cheats on you with a
one night stance yeah I don't think it
needs to be the end all be all I don't
think it's an excuse to end a marriage
and I also think a lot of the time it is
hard for men to get sex they have to
work to get it so my question is a lot
of times even when they're married they
still have to work to get sex as a wife
why is your husband seeking sex from
somebody else you know it's one thing if
you've married an a big star and maybe
there's women throwing themselves at him
left or right but that's not the norm
most people marry average people most
people marry average people so my
question is why is he going out of his
way to get sex from somebody else it
says that it's lacking in the
relationship and a lot of times women
aren't as innocent as we pretend to be a
lot of times we nag a lot of times we
criticize and make him not feel like a
man a lot of times we starve our
husbands upset like there are Parts
where we play into the situation yeah I
guess this woman Dr Laura offers No
Nonsense advice infused with a strong
sense of Ethics accountability and
personal responsibility she's been doing
it successfully for more than 40 years
touching millions of listeners weekly so
let's pull up the clip of her back now
we are welcome back to Hann coms Now new
tonight the uh New York Times just
reporting theid of the escort allegedly
hired by Governor Spitzer the New York
Times reporting the woman who goes by
the name as Kirsten is 22-year-old
Ashley Alexander Dupre of New Jersey uh
we're now joined by I'm sure this will
come up by the way Dr Laura sler author
of the new book stop whining start
living which we'll talk about in just a
moment now the same paragraph
with all right so you're on the some
Morning Show today right today show
yesterday yesterday I was today all
right
and uh you talk about this whole
incident and you talk no actually I
never did and that was the point well
they asked you about it they asked me in
general terms cheat right and you talk
about I said I can't talk about the
spiters because I don't know anything
about them but you did talk about the
whole issue of cheating and you said
that the wife uh does not focus on the
needs and the feelings sexually
personally to make him feel like a man
to make him feel like a success to make
him her hero and those kinds of comments
you said the cheating was decision to
repair what's damaged and to feed
himself where he's starving sounds like
you're making excuses for men who cheat
and blaming and you're not hearing this
for the first time that you're blaming
the woman when a man commits adultery
okay the first part of that which they
left out of course was that I said if a
man is a narcissist a sociopath bipolar
a number of things all bets are off he's
a jerk however yeah it is and you know I
was here for the proper care and feeding
of husbands book and we discussed this
then when women do not when women ignore
neglect don't nurture don't love don't
kiss up don't do all those wonderful
things for their husbands they're more
susceptible that doesn't mean they are
not responsible for their who treats on
his wife doesn't the responsibility lie
with that adulterer responsibility that
decision resp for cheating is his the
responsibility for mistreating her man
is hers and just because a man treats
does not mean he was mistreated he could
just be a horny guy who oh never heard
that word before as I said if he's
narcissistic sociopathic then all bets
are off right then he's a jerk and
aren't most men who cheat on their wives
fall in that category they're
narcissistic or they've got they're not
respecting their wives no the the wives
haven't been respecting them and it's
interesting because in my book well two
things I want to tell you about call
girls in that book the proper care and
feeding of husband you could tell me a
lot more than I could tell you probably
I'm glad to hear that but uh uh in the
book I got a letter from a call girl an
ex call girl who said that most of the
guys are married who come to her very
rarely is it to have sex most of the
time it's to have some woman actually
pay attention to them and today they had
a hooker on the Today Show who was asked
what would you suggest to a woman if she
thinks her husband is seeing a hooker or
having an affair and the call girl said
saw that they put extra effort into
making their own relationship stronger
and closer so when a hooker says that
it's okay when I say it I'm blaming the
wife well well sometimes the men are
selfish in some cases some and you you
always say that I always have that
disclaimer a jerk is a jerk why is it
every time Dr Laur is on the show my
face gets beat red I talk about sex you
caused him to do it I blame you you're
here what did I get caus well you and
your whatever the word you used good
grief word we that whatever I got to
move on important matters with my friend
Dr Laur first of all I love the book
because I think we whine too much yes
and when you whine there is a point and
you go through this in the book you can
be sad you can be miserable and upset
you give yourself if I recall what two
days and then it's time to get over it
and start living your life and don't
wallow in in problems right well you
notice the book is not entitled don't
whine because I think there are a
certain amount of things to whine about
when the blog is feere and even the New
York Times went crazy over Meredith
Fiera being a gast that blamed you know
Mis misrepresenting what I said uh I was
whining because with me was this
Anthropologist who said you know what
men who have high foreheads and
protruding brows have a lot of
testosterone and they're more likely to
cheat nobody commented about that all
right I said women got to love up their
husband's to so I spent the morning
after that whining you see but whining
over something reasonable vents it gets
you some compassion from your friends
which helps youal calm down it gives you
some advice and suggestions and it gives
you gives you the opportunity to pull
yourself together and think about what
you're going to do you see so whining as
an end in itself takes away the value of
I read your books I listen to your radio
show I think you give great advice I
think it's common sense you know you go
through in the brand new book here treat
your spouse as if you loved him or her
with your last breath no matter how
contrary that you might feel at any
moment at any one moment at any one
moment in your last book you talked
about you know if your spouse want sex
have sex uh unless you have a terrible
headache or really something but most
times don't deny your spouse and people
got all shock you said that both ways
both ways of course in other words serve
your me if you don't love now wait a
minute love is about making their life
worthwhile so if you're hungry and I'm
not hungry I'll make you sandwich you
don't have to blush yet I didn't go
anywhere if you're feeling sexy and I
just have too much on my mind I can
still pleasure you oh jeez oh see your
people hold on to yourselves here but
the point is that I tell women because
women are a little slower to get their
engines can I say something I agree with
you I think we should I think couples
should serve each other that's always
that's all you're saying hey what
happens what happens after the sandwich
all right well I usually feel more
relaxed after I've eaten chances are you
have been here before the chaos in the
markets oil and stocks just when you
thought it was safe and interest rates
were Rising new threats come out of
nowhere tensions are boiling from Asia
to Europe and adaptation is the key here
to safeguarding your wealth you may not
have considered gold before and it's not
speculation but insurance and right now
you need some insurance Noble gold
Investments has been protecting
investors from disaster for years with
precious metals so if you're worried it
might be time to take a fresh look at
gold and silver gold is a proven Safe
Haven shield for your portfolio and a
volatility balance against uncertainty
if it helps Noble gold Investments is
offering a free 3o silver America virtue
coin with its new IAS this month if you
open up your Noble gold Investments IAS
or 401K rollover you can claim your coin
today remember crisis Cruise portfolios
waiver and gold insulate secure yourself
against all threats go to Noble gold
investments.com now that's noblegold
investments.com the only gold company
that I
trust
I've never seen her before but I thought
she was so funny I thought she was
brilliant I thought she was brilliant I
think she spoke very clearly she made it
very clear exactly what she's saying but
I have no doubt that there are lots and
lots of people only hear what they want
to hear and it's the same thing that I
see with you all the time they they can
only hear so far as their own perception
allows them to and they project their
own insecurities what if he's abusive on
yeah it's instantly what if this what if
this what if this it's like okay we all
know that like she says there are
narcissists in the world there are jerks
in the world can't be saying the word
jerk around you Americans too long but
yeah there's there's douchebags dicks in
the world right are the majority people
those people and the thing that she is
bringing to light hookers are saying
that the rule is not a jerk the rule is
that you guys are neglecting your
husband and just look at look at things
like the whatever podcast that episode
where they had Candace Owens on there
and there was she says how she's
fascinated by hookers and that and women
who are I think these call out girls
like it's the same thing basically
they're saying the same thing so it's
like oh it's okay for them to say it but
you can't say it yeah it's like I'm evil
I'm Evil by saying ladies ladies ladies
stop leaving your husbands over cheating
especially if you haven't slept with him
in a long time I think that's not fair I
think a lot of women put their husbands
in bad situations because they haven't
slept with him it is so common for women
to stop sleeping sleeping with them
after two children interview any divorce
attorney they will tell you the same
thing there are sexless marriages where
men haven't had sex in years sometimes
what did you think was going to happen
and even if they are sleeping with him I
mean you're not you're you're not
nagging it all you're not belittling him
like women we're not these perfect
angels we have flaws and places where we
can improve and it's all about how we
view love isn't it like I think what
what really struck me with what she was
saying is is the idea of um love is
about serving each other it's about
every day wanting to make someone else's
life better I think in our culture the
meaning of Love at least today has
completely flipped and it's become what
does this person bring to me how many
times is the conversation on the show
you know how many times do we hear it
what do you bring to the table what do
you bring to the table and we always ask
this whether it be to men or women the
question is always what do you bring to
me it's never what can I provide to you
and and we've lost this service itude
attitude in our culture even when we
look at how people work People of Our
Generation it's always what does the job
bring for me what benefits does the job
bring for me what salary is it what what
comes with it whereas When I Look to say
my dad's generation it was what can what
can I do in the job and it was you know
what can I do for society what can I do
for society and they just get on with it
we've lost the ability to serve what's
really sad about that is it's this idea
that people don't understand that things
are often not what they seem so you say
you serve right that sounds like you're
giving and giving and giving and it
makes almost the presumption that you're
getting nothing back but actually when
you're serving you get the most
fulfillment because it's it's if you're
healthy and you're not a narcissist or
anything like that you get so much out
of serving other people because it makes
you feel good because you're making
someone else feel good you know they
always say don't don't give to receive
and and giving makes people feel good
good why do you think millionaires you
know without government intervention
people who have a lot of money tend to
give to charity more why why would they
do that why would they just give their
money away because it must make them
feel good like they have enough money
they you know but people just people
have misconstrued things now and
everything become very selfish and
narcissistic actually where people think
oh rich people only give money to
charity to make themselves look better
it's like actually speaks to you more
than it does the millionaire because
you've come to that you know it reminds
me of a Catholic prayer it's like for
word is in it's like Lord make make it's
Lord make me an instrument of your peace
where there's hatred let there so love
where there's injury pardon doubt Faith
despair hope Darkness life and sadness
joy for it is in giving that we receive
for is it is in pardoning that we are
pardoned and it isn't dying that we are
pouring to eternal life so absolutely so
it's like um I I think about that a lot
because he's even saying by forgiving
you're forgiven you know and it's even
like in giving you're you're being given
the most and the most most like happy
people I see are the most selfless ones
and also I think if it is a situation
where again this is excluding the
exceptions excluding the people who are
nasty excluding the people who are
psychopaths narcissists whatever that is
in most normal relationships if a
problem arises whether it be cheating
whether it be something else if your
first thought is this person is no
longer serving me I'm going to get rid
of them that is a narcissistic trait
that is narcissism because that says
that you view people with objects that
bring value to your life rather than
what you can bring to them so actually
that it really really speaks to the
society and the culture that we live in
because it actually shows that all of
these people who who tend to say so that
that gentleman on there said um aren't
the guys who isn't cheating on your wife
automatically going to put you in the
group of say being a narcissist actually
seeing a problem arise and automat
automatically discarding that person
because they're no longer of use to you
says that you view that person like an
object well and and you're not and and
the women it's like are you perfect
you've never flirted with another guy
and they'll say oh no never I'm like
really never because really like when I
think about cheating women we can't live
without attention from them if you ask
women would you rather be young forever
or have sex with the hottest person
alive most women would rather pick the
you yeah so what does that say that says
we value looking young or if you ask a
guy the same question he's like me the
models baby give me where's where's
Margot Robbie at 22 not
32 but I'm thinking like you've never as
a woman accepted attention from other
men and you know honestly this this is
going to be an unpopular opinion I I
would tell men if you have kids and a
family and whatever if you find out she
accepted attention from another guy I
think that can be worked through the
same way I think that casual sex for a
guy can be worked through and it's like
what what does love say say to you
realistically what does love say to you
because if you're something happens say
they cheat it's a one night stand or
whatever and you know deep down in
yourself that things between you guys
haven't been good for a while that just
says to you your love your love is empty
because it's just like it's almost as if
you've waited for an excuse to go I'm
done with you instead of you've seen
that a problems arised and you should be
saying What's led us because if you're
in a relationship you're supposed to be
a team What's led us to the point where
he's had to go out and get sex from
someone else and then you could look to
yourself and go what could I have done
that might have prevented him getting to
that point and he should be taking equal
responsibility for the fact that he's
done that the the the burden of cheating
lies absolutely on him how you got to
that point right is a two-way streak
because there's two of you in a
relationship and and that's not to say
that you're to blame it just says that
there's two people in a relationship
women act like oh I did nothing wrong
and I'm just like really you did nothing
wrong and it almost shows their
narcissism because it's like you were
the really you were the perfect wife
yeah and he just okay all right ladies
it's a big red flag to me if someone
when when they talk about a relationship
it's they they present themselves as
having not done anything wrong lack of
accountability male or female is a red
flag to me because I'm like no no human
being on this Earth is perfect you
really can't find one thing wrong with
yourself nothing you could have improved
so you're perfect they're always perfect
it's always so okay um the comment
section says I agree with Dr Laura on
her advice in almost every situation
males deserve and need women to love
them in a perfect way she describes
today's women are selfish and can
benefit from her wisdom uh purple song
bird says the victim this word gets
overused these days cheating is not a
crime I have been cheated on in the past
and it hurt but I was not a victim
people stray because they are either
looking for something they are not
getting at home or ultimately they
aren't committed to the other person
many of us don't know how to ask for
what we want a relationship is no place
to keep score I gave last time now it's
your turn you hurt me now I get to hurt
you people have gotten way off track oh
my gosh that is the way the way women
talk about getting cheated on is like
it's like you think they went to war or
something I'm like ladies like it
doesn't and this is why I said they all
look at me like I'm crazy when I say
doesn't have to be a big deal no it
doesn't look it you can be her I I know
someone I know someone from like I won't
say where but I know a family right they
had like four kids and the husband uh
cheated on the wife with a strip okay he
hooked up with a stri now does that have
to be the end of the world no I'm not
saying you should have did it all right
obviously yes he shouldn't have been at
that club but I mean you're going to you
guys have four kids together
he he was a successful sales guy really
really successful guy and he hooked up
with a and also what's important to ask
is in the majority of these
situations uh the guy is apologetic and
does realized so it's like it would be a
different scenario if if in that
situation he' hooked up with the
stripper and he had come to the
relationship and said I've done this
listen I don't want to be with you
anymore I don't want to have anything to
do with the kids but it's like if he's
coming to the
incident and saying yeah I did this and
I'm sorry and I want to work through it
or whatever like and you're still with a
family of four kids you're still going
to be like no you've broken my trust
youve betrayed me they stayed together
like they yeah they did and that's the
thing they never tell any of the stories
where the couple actually works through
it and gets better it's all and you know
in all honesty I I know the couple and
the woman I mean she she had her issu
with like nagging and kind of belittling
him too so sometimes guys just want to
feel like a man and this comment really
really speaks to the the Nuance of
reality and how complex something like a
relationship really is because you know
it's a lot of people might get triggered
by this particular comment where she's
she's saying I've been cheated on and I
wasn't a victim I was hurt but I wasn't
a victim but she also speaks again it's
two people yes the man has done The
Incident That's brought the pain but
there would have been pain on his part
leading up to that and what's what
really spikes out to me here is many of
us don't know how to ask for what we
want um and that speaks to the the M's
accountability as well you know before
he got to that point did he communicate
there is something that's lacking here
or did he just stay silent and let his
wife slowly drain his voice and my yeah
well and my other question is our
generation has not been taught how to
actually forgive there are so many times
where it's such an ego thing where
people will say oh they did that to me
and I I always can tell people's mindset
when they say oh you can't just let
people walk all over you you'll look
stupid da d d but it's very much like a
it's like what you're going to go
through life and you have been perfect
to everybody around you you have never
been the villain in anybody's story
we're never taught how to actually
forgive and like work with people and
you know what's funny my dad and every
time I haven't listened to this I've
always regret it he always told me never
burn Bridge he said never burn a bridge
because you just never know you never
know yeah and my dad told me a story
where this person did something to my
dad that was like very very shady he
totally went behind his back whatever um
anyways a couple years go by my dad
doesn't burn the bridge he just like
lets it go whatever my dad is so good at
that like men are just very good at yeah
my dad's already good at that as well my
dad like doesn't have one thing my dad
said to me is um and it's probably the
same kind of thing but a lesson from my
dad was always don't hold grudges is
yeah yeah that's a my I think it's like
the same same kind so he said years
later this person came back to him ended
up helping him in a time he really
needed it and he never would have
thought because this person went there's
so much power in forgiveness and people
need to realize the harder something is
the more value the goal has so for
example let's say you climb you walk up
the road and it's a fairly Steep Hill
yeah right you feel pretty good when you
get to the top of that Hill cuz halfway
up you were thinking I couldn't thought
I was going to die imagine climbing
Mount Everest The Climb is so much
harder but when you get to the top it's
wow I've climbed Mount Everest
forgiveness is hard because it requires
you to let go of pain and pain is
something that's really really hard to
to let go of pain hurts pain sucks so
the ability to be able to get through
that and to say to the person who hurt
you I forgive you even if you don't say
it to them to be able to let go of the
pain yourself and say I forgive that
person there is so much value in that
because it's so hard yeah it's so hard
and we know this value is determined by
scarcity a lot of people don't know how
to forgive and it's not about them
either a lot of times people think like
forgiveness is about the other person
it's it's it's really not it's about
setting yourself free of the the the
damage that's been done correct our top
comment from last episode was Rosie C
Spencer and he says that women should be
held accountable for what they do even
young women guys if you have a comment
that you want to leave and that you want
me to read next episode make sure you
like your favorite comment below what do
you think that I think yeah absolutely I
mean how are older women supposed to be
able to take accountability if it's not
been a practice that they've had since
they were young good point how will we
learn if we don't start from a young age
absolutely guys thank you for watching
make sure you like the video on your way
out and subscribe to the channel also
get yourself a women shouldn't vote
sweatshirt and a whale sweatshirt sign
up for our email list so we can keep in
contact with if we ever get kicked off
of YouTube like the video guys I'll talk
to you next time